- [Instructor] What I would like to do
in this video is get some practice
estimating the product
of multi-digit numbers
and there's no better way of getting
practice than just trying it ourselves.
And so right over here, it says
estimate 29 times 3,198.
Why don't you pause this video
and try to estimate this?
And of course you can do this by
multiplying this out on
paper or using a calculator,
but this is a useful skill,
try to do it in your head.
See if you can estimate
what this is going to be.
Well, before even
looking at these answers,
I would say this is going to
be approximately equal to ...
Let's see, 29 is awfully close to 30,
and then I could multiply that times,
I could either multiply
that times 32 hundred,
which is awfully close to 3,198,
or if I wanted an even
more rough approximation,
I could say that's roughly equal
to 30 times three thousand.
So if I did 30 times three thousand,
three times three is equal to nine,
and then I have one,
two, three, four zeroes.
One, two, three, four zeroes.
And actually my
approximation, it turns out,
is here, right over here, 90 thousand.
Now if I wanted a slightly
better approximation,
I could have said this is approximately
equal to 30 times 3,200,
and this you could also do in your head.
You could say, well,
what is three times 32?
Well, that is gonna be 96, and then
you have one, two, three zeroes.
One, two, three zeroes, so this
would be a slightly better approximation,
and if this is what you
got, the closest answer
here is still going to
be equal to 90 thousand.
Let's do another example.
So here, we are asked to
estimate 137 times 18.
So pause this video again and see
if you can come up with an estimate.
Try to do it in your head.
Well, there's once again many
ways of trying to tackle it.
The way I would tackle it, I would say,
well, that's pretty close to 140 times 20,
and then this would be
equal to 14 times two is 28,
and then we have two zeroes here,
so that would be roughly 28 hundred,
but when I look over here,
there is no 28 hundred,
and so maybe the closest
one right over here
is two thousand, so that would be my,
that could be an approximation.
Another way, it looks actually
the way that they did it, they even
did a coarser approximation,
they rounded this
to the nearest hundred, and so they said
this is approximately
equal to one hundred times
and they rounded this to the nearest ten,
one hundred times 20
which is even easier to do
in your head, which is
equal to two thousand,
which is this choice that
they got right over here.